I'm Dan Quinn originally from clay in
Virginia and I created the video about
the tears of wine that form around the
edge of wine glasses
most people who drink wine have seen the
weird drops that form around the side of
the glass traditionally they're called
tears or legs of wine but what most
people don't realize is that if you
watch patiently these drops are actually
moving around my favorite part is when
I'll be at a party or something and
someone has a glass of wine and they're
twirling around and they see the legs of
wine and the tears of wine and they say
Oh Dan you know come explain this to us
students before lab like I can I can see
them in the hallways watching my videos
and then also during lab I'll sometimes
they'll like have it on their phone and
they'll like whoa what did you do in the
video just just bring it up on your
phone oh my his students think it's
super cool
they the second they heard up that I had
a video on YouTube they were like really
excited the mushy food lands in your
stomach
we're gastric acid and chemicals break
down the food even more to be a really
good teacher you just have to be a
really good communicator and you need to
also be able to relate to your students
I think that a good teacher
is engaged and supportive and
responsible and should treat his or her
students with like respect if you put
yourself in an ivory tower or spew and
forth wisdom unto the masses like that's
not gonna help anybody the truth is your
students are just as smart as you are
you just happen to know a little bit
more than them for the moment you know
when you're teaching it you know it all
very well but when you're telling it
when you're teaching it to someone else
you can't you have to think of what
they're thinking and when I make the
videos I sort of keep in mind what
questions pop into their head first if
you're telling me that we have a seeing
threshold just like how we have a
hearing threshold wouldn't that mean
that there's light waves I think what's
really important is that they love it
because when a teacher loves something
and they teach it to you you sort of
love it too usually when I create a new
video it's because I found something
that's really exciting that I want to
talk about to people and so I kind of
can't not talk about it and I want to
get it all into one thing
that can be my packaged you know
delivery of this idea to the world the
thing that that excites me the most
about video making is actually YouTube
comments because of the nature of the
content that I produced it didn't really
attract a whole lot of trolls so all of
the comments were just uniformly
constructive or helpful or they would
say David you screwed up here but they
would say it like real politely other
fantastic comments include that was
tolerable and I did not want to blow my
brains out after watching your video
those are from harsher critics okay so
one of my biggest worries about putting
things on YouTube you know YouTube's
notorious for critical comments and I
don't care about that if that's much
better than no comments in my mind but I
was worried that my mom might you know
she's naturally gonna watch video she
cares about what her son's doing and I
don't want her to see people saying bad
things about us so no mother wants that
so I was a little bit stressed about
that to start because I don't care
that's just critical feedback especially
with education so it was a bit of a
relief when at least you know so far
people are by and large very very nice
about it the the initial feedback I got
from my students about the videos and
providing that has just been amazing and
I never thought that it would be as as
well received and of course I also never
thought that that would lead to being
here at Khan Academy and so I would I
would encourage anyone who wants to do
this who thinks they have something to
say about history science mathematics -
- just go out there and and give it to
the world I feel like teaching is the
best way to learn sometimes each
professor each teacher each tutor has
their own style and I think any person
can bring out their own style from their
personality from the way they think
about things that's something that only
they can offer and they can offer it the
best I hope my videos show that know if
you break it down into one step after
the other you can really understand even
the most complex phenomenon